where is your solution because I don't
see one at the moment we are
contravening international law the
people who pretend to care about these
people never seem to have a solution to
the problem there's been a huge backlash
over how he compared the government's
rhetoric on migrants to the rhetoric in
the 30s in Germany from Adolf Hitler and
the Nazis in his tweet suggested the
home secretary's response to the small
boats crisis used quotes language that
is not dissimilar to that used by
Germany in the 30s well joining me now
to discuss this writer and commentator
Larissa Kennedy and comedian Constantine
kissing who moved to New chap in Russia
when he's 11. so let me start with you
uh Larissa on this when you read what
gynecas said did you think that was a
fair analogy to contrast this government
with a regime that was building in the
30s in Germany which was to go on to
slaughter 12 million people to be
absolutely clear what Gary lineker said
is that and I'm paraphrasing here but
the language used to justify what is
happening here with this bill with this
proposal from the government is akin to
language that was used in the 1930s in
Germany so I think it's it's really
difficult to begin then talking about
policies and actions because that is
something entirely different because I
think what Gary was trying to insinuate
is that we need to be cautious of the
slippery slope here which is well
documented which is that language and
the dehumanization that language can do
is very very powerful in leading down
that slippery slope well it is it is
right but it is but I would argue I'll
bring Constantine in here my issue with
this is you talk about slippery slope
the moment you get into 1930s Germany uh
you evoke memory of Adolf Hitler and the
Nazis and the Holocaust and 12 million
people being you know murdered
exterminated in concentration camps six
million Jews in concentration camps and
so on I just think that is a slippery
slope and the moment to me anyone
invokes that in relation to a current
government like this conservative
government to me you're losing the
argument because you're using an
extremity of a debate which just Bears
no relation to reality well right and
I'm not particularly easily offended so
I'm not offended by his comments but the
problem we've got here is not so much
that he said something silly or
insensitive for me the problem is it's
completely inaccurate tens of thousands
of people we're not trying to get into
Germany on small boats and that is I'm
afraid the real problem with this whole
argument is the people who want to
demonize Britain is This Racist hellhole
can never seem to explain why tens of
thousands of people like me want to come
to this country and settle here and some
of them do so illegally even by breaking
the law and putting themselves in danger
which is something actually I think we
should all be concerned about and should
be seeking to end yeah I mean my problem
Arissa with this Gary Gary doesn't have
a solution to one of the biggest
problems with the small boats at the
moment which is a third of the people
coming in on the small boats are young
perfectly healthy non-vulnerable
Albanian men who are being recruited
they suspect mainly for gangs and
already in the UK they're being brought
over by criminal gangs they're spending
thousands of pounds to do it so they're
not short of a few quid but these aren't
the most vulnerable oppressed people
from war-torn countries they're coming
from a perfectly safe country and they
you they're abusing our system but I
don't see anything in Gary's statement
about that reality of the people coming
over on these small boats in large
numbers to be really clear we are often
talking about people being trafficked
here and in fact by not being
trafficking people of their rights
that there are people being trafficked
to the UK there are being people people
repeat the question and so you know
better than genocide watch you know
better let me repeat my question because
your rights organizations
let me repeat my question a third of the
000 or so people who came over last year
to the UK on small boats were Albanian
young men perfectly healthy not
vulnerable not oppressed people for more
torn countries that's a that's a fact a
statistical fact and when I saw that I
found that alarming that said to me the
system was being gained now there are
other people who are coming from
war-torn countries in fact Britain has
been leading the way in putting up
people from Ukraine from Afghanistan and
other genuine war-torn places that is a
different issue but what would you do
about all these young Albanian men
coming in who are not from more torn
countries and just want to come in
without doing it legally what would I do
well I don't think my first action would
be to strip all of those all
three-thirds of those groups of their
rights illegally by contravening
international law I don't know how the
the question is being reversed rather
than the government's actions actually
being interrogated because at the moment
we are contravening international law in
1951 we signed up to the conventional
refugees saying that we would not uh you
know put extra pressure or you know
impose sanctions on those who came via
illegal entry we signed up to that as a
country so it's not for me to now sit
here and debate okay
this is a problem
I mean there certainly is going to be a
massive legal route about this but what
is your response to that well this is
exactly the problem and this is nothing
personal to Larissa but the people who
who pretend to care about these people
never seem to have a solution to the
problem and the reason is they haven't
thought about the issue at all now look
at the point you made about people from
Albania being smuggled let's say that
they are being smuggled why are they
being smuggled into this country because
we allow them to be to be coming in here
in these small boats and we don't do
anything to prevent it from happening
and we don't do anything to
disincentivize these smuggling gang from
doing it right and all we have to do by
the way is declare Albania a safe
country so that no one who comes here
from Albania illegally is entitled to
Asylum it's not very difficult if you
actually care about the issue and my
biggest concern is someone who like you
is proud of Britain for helping people
who are coming from genuine uh need is
that if we continue to make the British
public feel like they're being taken for
a ride and of course they're right to
feel that way once we spend seven
million pounds a day accommodating these
people if we continue down that path
then eventually people are going to get
fed up and say we don't want anyone
coming in we don't care about the
circumstances and then the very people
that these woke lovies like Gary lineker
pretend to care about are going to be
the one that suffer in the end I mean to
be fair to gardenica everyone shouted
them well if you care so much take one
of them into your house and he did he
took in a young boy Refugee and he did
take care of him and he's very proud of
him and so he did actually practice what
he preached um thank you both but that's
not the solution repairs no no I totally
agree and I I've in my son column
tonight I've I've said where is the
answer Gary and secure's Dharma and
others criticizing the government where
is your solution because I don't see one
and the problem with allowing so many
obvious economic migrants to come in
illegally is that you are then taking
attention and money and resource away
from the people who really need it and
that is what we should be focused on as
a country but Larissa Constantine thank
you both very much indeed you've got to
have a short break coming you're going
to bring in isabello shot familiar to
this Parish I think certainly to you
Richard uh we're gonna pick up on that
and also get some reaction to what